ah better protect your bubble calm proud
sponsors of swype on Sky News you're
watching swype coming up on the show
this week drumroll please we're making
music from thin air a smart alarm clock
that won't disturb your other half and
we head off on an emotional journey with
a slice of bread yes really welcome to
swipe this week we're getting musical
now some of you watching right now might
already know how to play a musical
instrument how many of you have stuck
with it for years because think if
you're a drummer you've got to lug the
kit around everywhere you need your own
group of roadies but imagine if you
could fold up your drum kit and put it
in a rucksack here's will the drum is
one of the oldest instruments in the
world but now it's had an upgrade what
you're seeing here is an invention
called arrow drums it uses motion
sensors LEDs and a high-speed camera to
track your hand and foot movements and a
computer converts this into sound it's
very sensitive we use a high-speed
camera to make sure that we can
accurately determine the speed that the
sticks are moving and this is important
to you know provide an authentic
drumming experience when you hit softly
and you expect to hear a very soft note
and when you hit hard you expect to hear
an accent it note so we put a lot of
work into you know modeling the volume
responsive real drums traditional drum
kits take up a lot of space and are
expensive so for many aspiring drummers
just getting your hands on a full set is
a real challenge a Kickstarter project
called djembe thinks it's got around
this by putting an entire set on a
touchpad and once you link it up with an
app you can choose your sound when a
drummer hits one of John base-10 pads
what they're really doing is putting
pressure on a special type of sensor
called a force sensing resistor our
electronics constantly read these
sensors and send the data into an iPad
where our software recognizes the
drummer's gestures and converts that
into music making your instruments more
portable is useful but does one as
successful as the drum really need to
evolve this technology is allowing
people to practice that otherwise would
not practice having said that if you're
a drunk a player I think there is no
substitute for getting a real drum kit
so I think the two work well together I
think they can support each other but I
don't think one replaces the other
rogerlinn has been at the forefront of
music technology for years his drum
computer created the beats on Michael
Jackson's Thriller and he thinks
acoustic instruments could be on their
way out you look 50 years in the future
do you really think everyone's going to
be playing old acoustic guitars and
pianos and saxophones and violins I
think it's most people would believe
that there's going to be some new
electronic is front or a variety of new
electronic instruments the people who
were playing and if you just backtrack
from there you see a progression towards
that state it might be a while yet
before machines take over completely
well sergeant Scott you will makes all
that tech sound so easy to use doesn't
he with me now is the co-developer of
arrow drums young levan and you're going
to show me how this kit works yeah sure
just take those drumsticks dicks have a
sit here also do I hear something
giving a single ready I'm going to put
those on your feet okay for the pedals
what are these as they reflect life like
something you'd wear when you're cycling
at night okay so they're like bicycle
reflectors but they're going to pick up
the movement of my feet yeah exactly so
so camera has a lamp that sense light to
them and so reflection looks a lot
brighter than everything is that's how
we track the motion I see a case of this
camera and this light is tracking my
motion right now yep my hands and feet
does that mean that I couldn't do this
outside outside in broad daylight no
because it would throw it up it would be
true too bright in the background yeah
you at night it'll work okay so forget
good I could go bust me at night yeah we
live in it people do you think someone
could genuinely learn the drums from
scratch just by using this yes
definitely it would be better to have a
teacher but this will build coordination
and you'd be able to learn grooves like
you would on a real kids yes but it
wouldn't feel the same is playing a real
kick it what is they wouldn't build the
upper body strength yeah it's not quite
for building stamina because it's a lot
easier to air drums and to hit a real
kid and it will also feel a bit
different but you do get feedback on
your wrist because you have a ristic in
your hand and you feel it in your pan
and you can also use your time for
rebound actually to drum fast so what's
next to you then what are the
instruments are in a hard one well glad
or phone is a good one we've had
requests yeah oh I love gonna come back
to you when you found that the initial
road i c'n ready as always you're
watching swipe stilt account we prepare
for mortal combat but first here's a
roundup of some of this week's other
tech news
nevermind the drums if you're sick of
being woken up by your partner's alarm
clock then you might like this a
Kickstarter project called wake uses
focused beams of light and ultrasonic
waves to get you up without disturbing
anyone else a sensor monitors your body
heat and a white LED slowly lights your
face to wake you up scientists in the
u.s. say they've created a mobile phone
battery that charges in just one minute
most batteries are made from lithium or
alkaline that this one's made of
aluminium which is supposed to be safer
the team at stanford university expects
it to last for seven and a half thousand
charges a typical lithium one gives you
1000 an exoskeleton for your ankles has
been developed to help people with
mobility problems it's made of carbon
fiber and uses a mechanical clutch
connected to a spring to support the
muscles the team behind it says those
who wear it will feel like they've just
taken off a five kilo backpack Amazon's
billionaire founder Jeff Bezos is to
launch a spaceship which could one day
take passengers into Earth's orbit his
firm Blue Origin has finished testing
the rocket engine and if test flights
are successful then it could be used to
one day fly three people to a height of
62 miles it's apparently likely to begin
flying commercially within 10 years
and now it's time for our games review
and this week we've got a rather unusual
title it features a slice of bread
trying to transform into a piece of
toast sound weird yeah we thought so too
here's Daniel Cooper the first game is
Mortal Kombat ten is the tenth more
combat it's been around for a good few
decades now and this is coming to
next-gen consoles pc and then going back
to the old ones in the foreseeable
future and it's you know it's the
characters you know is loads of them and
the thing that more combat does well i
think it's really known for has been
this kind of over-the-top outlandish
violent fighting game and it appeals to
people are really into fighting games
but also i can get pills so much wider
demographic you just want like pick up
and play and you know video games
sometimes get kind of a braided food
being violent but more converts a game
that kind of joyfully embraces that and
does so in a really silly flashing is
really kind of stuff that will make your
wins and pull back but it kinds of it a
little bit tongue-in-cheek next one is
dark souls 2 scholar of the first so now
this game came out last year really well
received so well I'm critically
acclaimed and this is kind of a
remastered version so if you've already
played the game it's kind of worth
picking up because it's technically
better graphics to improve throwing
rates improved and they've kind of
changed a few things you'll still be
surprised if you haven't played it's
probably the version to pick up now Dark
Souls is it's the sequel to why think
one of the best games ever made I swarm
but what the kind of known for has been
really difficult I think sometimes that
difficulty is overstated to the point
that it puts off new players embracing
the series and it's not too difficult
it's literally a video game the demands
er attention it says here are the rules
this is how you play and you
learn it and if you are you will really
enjoy it and enjoy the challenge so the
final game is a real serious game called
iron bread in which you play a piece of
bread who wants to make his journey to a
toasting surface ideally a toaster so
you kind of Traverse a variety of
domestic environment from bedrooms two
bathrooms and on your way to the toaster
or the turf things up to the surface
like a hobby or something like that you
don't want to pick up too much dirt so
you want to get there in as direct and
speedy fashion as possible because as
you move over surfaces you pick up
things like and licks all sorts and it's
a fluff rendering the bed inedible and
therefore not being able to fulfill its
life laundry
well that's it for this week but don't
forget to stay up to date with all the
latest tech stories on sky is pipe a las
smartphone apps sky nice calm and our
YouTube playlist off for you again next
week bye bye Archer better protect your
bubble calm proud sponsors of swype on
Sky News